school's out in Italy at least until the
middle of March an unexpected bonus for
many children but few parents are in
holiday mode the Prime Minister
announced the draconian step in a bid to
contain his country's coronavirus crisis
we felt it was the right thing to do to
suspend educational activity until the
15th of this month in this moment we are
concentrating on fighting with all
measures in order to obtain either a
containment of the virus or to delay the
diffusion of the virus because we have
hospital structures and a health system
no matter how excellent it is an
efficient that risks being overburdened
Italy is Europe's worst hit country in
the Kovach 19 coronavirus outbreak more
than 3000 cases have been confirmed here
with the number of deaths jumping by 28
in the past day alone the largest
cluster of infections is here in the
north of the country the government is
considering expanding quarantine areas
near the city of pagamo schools in this
region have already been closed as part
of the crackdown now all primary schools
colleges and universities nationwide
will shut their doors teachers are
giving them a lot of work to do at home
some of them are getting bored and
missing the social contact with the
other students and teachers are making
full use of technology to keep in touch
with their students you know using
different methods maybe a digital
platform like Moodle one's got a little
whatsapp group going with her students
grim - for sports fans with big football
games and other events being cancelled
or postponed no action at this Stadium
in Milan Italy Sports Minister signaled
matches could be held without fans
coming to watch
as far as sport is concerned we will try
to mediate between continuing sport
activities and taking care of
everybody's health at least temporary
transformation comes just weeks after
its first coronavirus cases were
identified Britain and other European
allies will be watching the impact
closely mindful that these are measures
they may soon have to take as well
Deborah Haynes Sky News